wo ist denn hier ist der poker ist ob
hey leute hier ist trotzen und ich bin
natürlich pokémon go sowie ziemlich
jeder gerade auf der ganzen welt und
eine person die ich aber auch getroffen
aber du hier ist will von filz physics
der hat auch ein wissens kanal und wir
machen heute meine videos über pokernews
auf jetzt
da sind wir wieder drin und zwar diesmal
nicht bei mir zu hause sondern im studio
von 56 aber es sieht ehrlich gesagt ja
fast genauso aus wieder ein stück man
muss sagen es ist ein bisschen auffällig
dass da auch nur wieder sohn erik ikea
regal ist und lustiges 1 sachen im
internet aber ich meine fühlt euch
direkt wie zu hause und es geht auch um
science-fiction genau
aber kommen wir zum thema ihr wollt also
ein echtes pokémon kreieren ein
richtiges lebewesen dass man streicheln
kann und das gefühl hat keine leichte
aufgabe aber es könnte sein dass das mit
aktuellen wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen gar nicht so weit entfernt
ist also die idee wurde ja eigentlich
schon im ersten drei six pack film
bekannt 1993 dort haben wissenschaftler
dinosaurier wiederbelebt um sie in einem
riesigen zu als attraktion zu zeigen und
geschafft haben die wissenschaftler das
mit moskitos die vor zehntausenden
jahren das blut der dinosaurier 1
gesorgt haben und dann aber als immer
weise im bernstein eingeschlossen wurden
und somit die saurier den es über jahre
geschützt haben
und was in den neunziger jahren noch als
science fiction abgetan wurde und im
film natürlich als katastrophe endete
könnte jetzt so ganz langsam schleichend
zur realität werden
denn wie die moskitos im film wurden
auch in der echten welt tiere
eingeschlossen zum beispiel von 1 bis zu
40.000 jahre alt könnten einige tiere
seien in der letzten zeit wieder
aufgetaucht sind
oder er aufgetaut bomben scherz also
aufgetaut denn sie sind nach ihrem tod
scheinbar eingefroren
von einer soliden eisschicht begraben
und somit vor aasfressern und verwesung
geschützt und auf diese weise konnten
zum beispiel wollhaarmammuts gefunden
werden die noch erstaunlich gut erhalten
sind und das wichtigste die auch noch
ihre dns besitzen ja zumindest teilweise
denn wasser und mikroorganismen
beschleunigen leider den verfall von dns
trotzdem haben wissenschaftler der
harvard university vor kurzem angefangen
die dns von den wollhaarmammuts die
gefunden wurde zu sammeln und die
einzelteile die überall gefunden wurden
zusammenzusetzen
das ziel ist es wirklich ein echtes
leben des mammut wiederherzustellen und
am ende sogar die ganze spezies
wiederzubeleben das war schon relativ
krasse der ganze prozess ist aber
unglaublich schwierig und sehr
zeitaufwendig denn wir verstehen häufig
noch überhaupt nicht welcher teil eines
dms strangs welchen einfluss auf das
lebewesen also verschiedene teile können
sich gegenseitig beeinflussen
oft kann eingenommen zwei verschiedene
effekte haben die scheinbar überhaupt
nichts miteinander zu tun haben
und manchmal sind auch große
streckenabschnitte der dns völlig
überflüssig und haben gar keinen effekt
ich habe bestimmt schon mal gehört dass
wir circa 98 unserer den ersten teil wir
haben ein paar genommen die absicht
haben und affen haben ein paar die wir
nicht haben aber diese zwei prozent sind
der unterschied zwischen einem affen und
uns die kleinsten veränderungen können
also die größten auswirkungen haben und
das ergebnis total verändern oder
umgekehrt
und genau deshalb ist es auch so
schwierig für die forscher denn sie
müssen immer wieder überprüfen ob die
änderungen den gewünschten effekt haben
als basis beginnen sie mit denen von
denen sie genau wissen dass sie
funktionieren und die dem mammut recht
ähnlich sind zum beispiel den
asiatischen elefanten ausgehen davon
haben die wissenschaftler dann teile der
mammuts erst mit einer hochmodernen
genmanipulation methode namens crystal
in die elefanten dns eingefügt der
nächste schritt ist dann diese kreuzung
in einer künstlichen gebärmutter zum
leben zu erwecken
wenn das funktioniert hat und die dns
änderungen den wirklich auch erwarteten
effekt auf das elefantenbaby haben dann
wird man weiter machen und immer mehr
dns ersetzen und so die theorie dann
irgendwann mal wenn mammut erhalten und
allerspätestens hier schalten sich
moralische bedenken ein oder man ist es
okay lebewesen zu kreuzen und
ausgestorbene spezies zurückzubringen
die man die einen sagen dass wir schon
so viele tierarten ausgerottet haben
dass wir nur noch anfangen könnten sie
wieder zurück zu bringen und die anderen
entgegnen
hey lass uns doch einfach mal das geld
lieber dafür ausgeben die tierarten die
uns noch bleiben zu beschützen was man
die zum thema ich bin gespannt über eure
meinung schreibt sie doch bitte unten in
die kommentare diskutiert mit uns
wir sind echt gespannt so lebewesen
zurückzulegen ist es halt wirklich eine
moralische grenze aber jetzt mal zurück
zu den pokémon bis wir den erst so gut
verstehen dass hier eigene lebensformen
ohne vorbild in der natur kreieren
können wird wohl noch sehr viel zeit ins
land gehen und vor allem auch viele
moralische und politische bedenken
müssen dafür noch geklärt werden aber
dann könnte es sein dass man wirklich in
einem pokédex freut sich ein pokémon
aussucht das wird dann kreiert und zudem
nach hause geschickt und das lebt dann
und funktioniert so per amazon schon
wahrscheinlicher dass direkt liefert ja
auch das so cool ist muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden ich bin gespannt was
ihr dazu unten in die kommentare
schreiben werde ansonsten aber noch ein
zweites video über pokémon gemacht und
zwar auf seinem kanal physics das könnt
euch da oben angucken und da geht es
darum wie man augmented reality benutzt
um halb drei pokémon go die pokémon zu
sehen und wie das wirklich genau
technisch funktioniert wie sehen uns auf
seinem kanal bis leicht
fantastisch die sind so fantastisch weil
ihr müsst das mit hochschulen machen
diesen film aus den 90ern